Good day, sal y jaramillo greets you with
the most outstanding headlines of the day,
that is, Rangel of the man harassed in the
death of the young woman who disappeared
last year, appeared before a judge
today, while the family of
Leslie Palacio conducted a  virtual meeting
to ask for the public's help in
locating the second suspect,
erick rangel ibarra, 25, and they also
asked eric to turn himself in.
investigators accuse eric of killing
leslie and fleeing the country along with his
father, josé rangel, 46, was
detained last week at the
mexico border the family asks that any
information on the whereabouts of eric
ibarra please call crime
stoppers or the authorities
and the board of commissioners is
scheduled to vote today on changing the name
of mccain international airport
from  to be approved the most
wanted airport would be named after former
state senator harris the
valley airport was named for mccai  n the former
senator from nevada who ran the state
in congress during the 1930s but
critics say machine had a
history of being racist and don't want
las vegas' international airport
named after the federal aviation agency as
well  would have to approve the change and
the cost could run as much as $2 million
and today at the state capitol
carstens series two key committees will
begin the difficult task of closing the
funding gap for the
nevada education system on monday hundreds of
teachers rallied in front of  to the
state legislature demanding increases in
salaries and fewer students in classrooms
per teacher some support an increase in
a tax on the mining industry to
cover the expenses faced by the
education system despite this in
July a new formula will take effect
to fund  the education system but
opponents say the formula
doesn't do enough to raise
funds and  it only changes the
distribution of funds now we move on with
the weather forecast a
partly sunny day with
temperatures in the 60s is expected the winds will
stay at 30 miles per hour
for today and will continue tomorrow
have a good day I am salt and jaramillo  and
this was Spanish edition
[Music]